- You're going to learn all about
what executive presence is
and how you can have more of it yourself.
And to do that, we are going to
be talking with a good friend
of mine, Allen Weiner.
He is the author of the new
book called The Highflier
Handbook, that book's all
about how you can be seen
as a leader at work, and then of course,
how you can become one yourself.
This is part one in a
three-part series with Alan
that we're doing, unpacking
three pieces of his book.
So, welcome, Allen. My first question
that I'm going to pitch right to you is,
what's the most common
question you get at your firm?
- For sure.
It's how could we develop
more executive presence in all
of the people who work here?
Certainly the senior executives,
but they're all using the
term executive presence.
- Right. And you've been working
now doing, you're like one
of the original executive coaches
specializing in communication.
There's a lot of 'em out there now,
but as the young people
say, you are one of the O.G,
the "original gangster" executive coaches.
That's right. So you've been,
you've been observing Fortune
500 CEOs for decades,
very C-suite executives.
You've been around people
with executive presence.
Some people call it pizazz,
some people call it flare.
Some people call charisma these days.
That's a big word today, charisma.
The through line,
through all this is
its executive presence.
So in terms of that phrase,
executive presence, what does
that mean to you in everyday language?
- Well, it actually started
with a second to five qualities
of credibility
and leadership, which has
always been called composure.
So when I first started hearing
the word executive presence,
it just took me back to all
of the early research on
what was called executive composure.
Composure. Like composed
not all over the place,
implies some kind
of control over the way
people express themselves.
- And then that comes across in the book
as you described it, instead of thinking
of executive presence, think of it as
that executive's presence in the room,
how people feel their presence.
- Right. You know, one of
my favorite stories is A CEO
who said to me, people
come into the office,
senior level people, and they talk to me,
and it sounds like a
drum solo in a jazz club.
It's all over the place.
And sometimes they run
up to the whiteboard
and just start drawing
stuff while they're talking.
Can you coach them
to sound more like a
composition like Mozart,
where there's a beginning,
middle, and an end?
That is what most of people
who are looking at this
experience all over the place.
- Right? So we see in a person
who's all over the place,
they're lacking that composure.
And we do not see that
as executive presence.
In contrast, you talk about control
and composure in terms of
how they present themselves.
And you mentioned, for
example, movies The Godfather.
Can you talk about more
what that self-control?
Because when we say control,
a lot of people think, oh,
you mean control other people?
But that's not what you're talking about.
You're talking about their
ability to stay in control
of themselves and to stay composed.
And you mentioned The Godfather,
which I think is a great example.
- Well, what happens there
is a, there's a scene
and Marlon Brando, who
plays the Godfather,
does not move a muscle while
another person coming to him
for a favor is asking for it.
So he sits generally like this
doesn't even nod his head.
And at the end of that
scene, he puts a cat down
and then finally talks a little himself.
And when he does that,
there's an amazing
amount of control there.
He says something like,
you come to me asking
for justice pause.
- Mm. - Yet you've never
invited me to your home.
Pause. So that means someone
exuding that same level
of control in a meeting.
Mike say something like,
that's what we're here for.
I want to hear more about
that. Why don't we get started?
It, it has that kind of quality to it.
- Very crisp communication, very composed
presentation of themselves.
They're not flailing around,
they're not doing a drum solo.
Interestingly, it's not a drum solo.
It's composed just like a, you know, just
- Musical piece. Just like
a composition piece. Right.
- You also talk about gravitas in the book
and how people often
ask, Hey, we want to speak
with more gravitas.
So what do they mean by that?
And how would you coach
people to have more gravitas?
- Well, gravitas has become
yet another word that's used
to describe executive composure.
Sometimes the call is, can
you help develop gravitas?
Well, as the word implies,
there's a certain gravity
to the way people express themselves.
The simplest example of that is in speed.
There's an example in my first
book where a president says,
Americans have a right to safety in
and around their homes.
That gravity of bringing the
tone of voice down, a tone as
he gets to the end, that's
what gravitas means.
Weightiness.
Now, hopefully the content
itself has weightiness,
but as I always tell clients,
we're a songwriting team.
I don't write the lyrics to the songs.
So I hope that your
content has gravity to it.
But as far as the description
of it, how you say it,
it's going to be a little slower
and the tones will be a little deeper.
- Yeah. And many times the
clients we work with have a lot
to say they have substance,
but their drum solo is
getting in the way of
that substance being
heard in a really clear
and concise way.
So what's your advice about Q&A?
I think at the end of the
chapter about executive presence,
there's a piece about
how to handle q and a,
because that's where a
lot of this self-control
and composure comes together,
because those are pressurized
moments for some people.
So what's your advice about q and A?
- This piece of advice about q
and a is one of the ones
I am most happy about.
This is something that I came
onto at the very beginning
of my practice.
All of the questions that all
of us get throughout our
lives are very, very similar
to the questions we were
asked on high school testing
and college testing.
And they were called true,
false, multiple choice,
fill in the blank and essay.
At least that's the way I experienced it.
So I tell my clients,
if you are asked a question in a meeting
that is seeking a yes
or a no, no matter how
complex the topic is,
it's still a true false question.
So if, for instance, Alex,
you asked me, do you think
that if we do it that
way it's going to work
and I have all of these
complex thoughts in my mind,
I still have to say to
myself, it's a true, false
or yes no question.
In other words, you could have
sent me an email that said,
Alan, you think this is
going to work true or false?
Circle T or F, right?
I think some people
probably ought to do that.
And multiple choice
questions have options.
So I'm telling my clients,
when you hear the options,
just say to yourself, is it A, B, or C?
You're lucky that they
gave you options when
they ask the question.
And then there's fill
in the blank questions,
which are always the ones where
you may not know the answer.
How much did we spend three quarters ago?
How much do you think
we'll spend on the same
thing next year?
When do you think you'll have it?
All those questions are fill in the blank.
And then finally, there are
essay questions, which are the,
what we've always come to
call open-ended questions.
They all start with why and how.
So I think that's how my
clients, how all of us ought
to think about handling q
and A. Does that make sense?
- Oh, it makes complete sense.
And you know, I've, I've
heard this from you before.
'cause I used to work with
you, and this is brilliant,
because so many people don't do this.
You ask them a very bottom line question
and they give you the essay answer instead
of giving you the yes no
or the fill in the blank,
or the multiple choice.
So you can distinguish yourself simply
by answering direct questions directly
and not going on a tangent
for every direct question.
And then of course, with essay questions,
sometimes you are asked a bigger question.
Just stay organized.
This is another thing that Alan teaches.
Give them talk in bullet points, right?
First, second, third,
keep your story organized,
keep it composed.
Again, this is part one
of a three-part series
on Allen's book, how
to Become a Highflier
(Highflier Handbook),
and How You Can Become a Leader At Work.
We're going to put links to his
book in the description below.
Please stay tuned for part two
where we're going to talk about whether
or not you're a born leader
and what you can do about it.
Thanks for hanging out with this, Allen.
- Well, thank you, Alex.